[Music]
this is Alan Dean Foster hi I'm Alan
Dean Foster and he's a science fiction
writer yes I am he might even be
familiar with one of his books in 1975 I
worked with George Lucas and wrote the
book version of Star Wars no way yes way
[Music]
this is Alan Dean Foster's office this
is the view from Alan Dean Foster's deck
this is how Alan Dean Foster met George
Lucas they were looking for someone to
do the book version of this science
fiction film that no one knew anything
about I was asked by my publisher if I'd
be interested I said yes and that's how
the book came to be it was the
opportunity of a lifetime
but it came with one pretty big caveat
George's name would be on the cover and
I couldn't admit to having ghostwritten
the book so he lied for a long time so I
had to lie to people's faces for 20
years
this is liar Alan Dean Foster's library
he's written a whole bunch of
novelizations Star Wars of course the
first three alien films The Chronicles
of Riddick Clash of the Titans and most
recently the force awakens and a lot of
other books too that's maybe the least
interesting thing about him there are
secrets that will forever remain
unrevealed these are Alan Dean Foster's
weightlifting trophies this is Alan Dean
Foster's bench press okay
Hughes Alan dean Foster's front kick got
that from Chuck Norris not a joke
here's Alan Dean Foster with his camera
he's recorded his travels on six
continents I'm stuck on this one planet
I'm determined to see as much of it as I
possibly can so how does a world-famous
crazy prolific sci-fi writer manage to
keep this up and still find time for his
writing well to stop learning is to
start to die didn't dizzy Darius arrest
me to say that yes he did
[Music]
you know John Ford only needed one take
[Music]
[Music]
I invented laser tag about 30 years ago
that game we all grew up playing high on
pizza and soda on a weekend night it was
invented here in Dallas Texas by this
guy George Carter laser tag might never
have happened if it hadn't been for one
particular movie the movie star wars I
was sitting at a theater in Las Vegas
and watched them going up and down the
halls of the ship shooting lasers at one
another gonna interrupt you there George
there are no actual lasers and laser tag
yeah I found out early on that there was
a rule against shooting lasers at people
there was a federal agency it didn't
allow that ah back to the story I
thought it put it in some sort of
context and make rules and we've got a
great game then George is an inventor he
has a lot of patents actually about a
dozen Oh a couple of his other
inventions motorized surfboard the first
modern bumper boat off-road vehicle
called the Snoopy but we're here in
Dallas to talk to him about a game he
called Photon
my first choice was laser tag and my
trademark attorney said that's too
generic you'll never be able to get a
trade name on that so we had to come up
with another name but it was a little
different than laser tag is today right
we promoted running and actually being
very competitive george's ideal game was
actually designed for twenty something
year old men not pre tween birthday
parties at family centers conceptually
it had three main tenants first
yeah the arena was very important we had
some facilities at very large arenas up
to 20,000 square feet the second the
field needs to be symmetrical so that
you had an equal advantage or no
advantage to either team and the third
ya mercy of environment with lots of
special effects lots of music lots of
lights lots of fog that that really got
you into the game so what happened well
photon toys in 1986 was a number-one
voiced category but it was actually kind
of an error
because it lowered our demographic age
George doesn't play laser tag anymore
call him a purist no I got other thing
to do - I've got other hobbies I grew up
playing laser tag out of Family Center
and having learned about photon yeah it
seems cooler but I like laser tag too
[Music]
when the young kids on the street found
out that I was working on Star Wars I
was like a god to them
those kids are now parents they've seen
the movies throughout the years there's
always in the back of their mind like
all I remember playing with it
Falcon I remember playing with the
x-wing and the TIE fighter
[Music]
to understand that you have a small part
of that kind of bigger world is is
pretty cool
[Music]
my name is Mark Boudreau and I've been
fortunate enough to work on Star Wars
toys since 1977
[Music]
amazing thing about Star Wars I don't
think it's really ever gone away it's
always been there vehicles has been sort
of what I really and the most passionate
about TIE fighters x-wings Rey's speeder
that I have always built models built
planes cars so they said hey Mark why
don't you go ahead and start working on
the Millennium Falcon
that's like sure why not
[Music]
and when Falcon is more than just a
machine
it really is a character that helps save
the day
it's more than just on to junk he wanted
to be able to provide an experience that
could extend in the film so when you
went to go see the movie you come right
back and you're playing with Luke you're
playing with Han you're playing with
Chewie and you're able to relive
everything that you saw in the film one
after I've gone to the force wherever
that might be this product will still be
there
grandkids from now will hopefully still
be enjoying Star Wars and we certainly
want to try to do our small part into
making sure that that continues it was a
dark time for Star Wars when CG
characters started popping into every
corner of the series but before Jorge
Arce stumbled into our collective
consciousness stores was all about
puppets which brings us to this guy I'm
Dave Barclay I'm a puppeteer and puppet
builder an animatronic effects
supervisor
you might recognize Dave better under
200 pounds of fiberglass and latex
because he was one of the puppeteers
inside Jabba the Hutt but to play the
most notorious gangster on Tatooine you
got to start somewhere and Dave well he
got his big break with a little green
man
[Music]
Notah was famously puppeteered by Frank
Oz the legend behind Cookie Monster and
Grover show you here and far but Yoda
was a complicated public and it took
four to five people working different
body parts to bring him to life Dave's
job was controlling Yodas eyes and ears
there's a sequence when Yoda is flooding
mark with a stick saying where he was
what he was doing and I'm doing a little
squint and subtle control on the eyes
yep right there that's me doing the eyes
there towards the end of the filming on
Empire Strikes Back Frank Oz was
performing Yoda and it became clear if
he had to move on to another film and he
wasn't going to be available so they
needed someone to take over from Yoda
and Frank nominated me I was 19 years
old so suddenly there I am with with
Yoda even a 19 years old
Dave's Yoda scenes blended perfectly
with Frank Oz that was Dee did you guys
see that let's take one more Dave did
such a good job they called him back and
asked him to run a new puppet called
jabba the hutt jabba the hutt was
probably the most complicated and
sophisticated animatronic puppet that
anyone had ever tried to build and it
took six to seven people to operate
inside Jabba was very claustrophobic
very close one person doing the left
hand the head movement in the tongue
another puppeteer doing the mechanical
tails not the puppeteer doing the
breathing on the air platters I did
Jabba's right hand and I did his jaw and
then I provided the voice onstage my
voice doesn't make it to scream but if
you've turned up on site will hear this
sort of voice where's my chalk right
as a child they weren't really any
movies that had puppeteers in them there
was a little bit here and there but
there were no solid characters like Yoda
and being part of the Yoda team which
really was the first performance
animatronic in movies was the start of
this huge growth that lasted about 20
years and as a puppeteer and the puppet
maker and someone who loves the movies
it was I was in there exactly the right
place at the right time and have had a
wonderful career doing what I adore so
I'd feel very lucky and privileged
[Music]
I got a call from an agent who wanted me
to go and audition for a new film called
The Empire Strikes Back
that was how I became a stormtrooper
this whole thing started because this
guy in our office is really into Star
Wars we all have one right after some
pretty serious internet sleuthing I've
tracked down this guy my name is Ralph
Morse
he was a stormtrooper in Star Wars
episodes 5 and 6 that's the Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi I II
was in the get my shuttle ready sequence
I decided to carry my gun left-handed
sidesaddle like I was carrying a shotgun
in the West and it's in the film you can
see it so we're talking about what it
felt like to be a stormtrooper and for
the most part that means what it felt
like to wear the costume I think all the
costumes were the same size and the
original model I think was about 5 foot
10 some of the guys were terribly tall
or terribly short found the costumes
unbearable and once you're in this thing
you can't really get out of it you
couldn't really sit down at all you have
to kind of lean to one side and if you
if you wanted to go to the bathroom you
needed to prepare yourself you needed
more than 30 second warning okay but
there is the helmet the iconic helmet
the first helmet they gave me I couldn't
see through the damn thing at all the
other problem we had were our boots they
had soles but they had no tread in the
soles so you would slide all over the
place I don't know a stormtrooper who
hasn't at some point fallen over oh all
right so it wasn't very glamorous but
it's still cool right cuz you know Star
Wars
[Music]
you